the relationships in the show I think
down to a tee they're very passionate
relationships we have kind of a Romeo
and Juliet situation going on on a
romance side of the spectrum we'll be on
our toes okay let's go let's do this
just when we thought we couldn't get
enough one calls the heart the team at
hallmark is serving up more hearty story
lines giving us the gift of when hope
calls new series new characters same
heart and soul like this for an hour on
the earth [ __ ]
yesterday PT was invited exclusively on
set to give you the inside scoop on
everything you need to know about this
heartwarming new show there may be
challenges going away we can face
together
my character is Grace and she is sisters
with Lillian I play Lillian Walsh grace
is my sister we were orphaned at a young
age and Lillian got adopted and Grace
didn't which separated them I was
adopted by another family and and she
was left at the orphanage growing up so
after years have gone by I go on a hunt
to find her and we finally reconnect
which is when we then decide to start
our own orphanage kind of to right the
wrongs that we felt happened when we
were growing up they're trying to make
the kids live a life that grace didn't
get to live so she is she has some kind
of a dark past but is pretty happy and
smiley about most things there's no
place to masturbate what are you
channeling when you take off the jocelyn
hat and put on the grace hat annum Green
Gables I just love how full of life she
is and she's positive and she's she's a
kind of crazy and funny and quirky Lily
Anna is definitely very pragmatic and
responsible and organized but she's also
independent and like a little bit fierce
like she has gone out of her way for a
couple years so like search down her
sister and that it's not easy no no cell
phones no Facebook what do you do of
course I'm a dog I don't know
welcome back dick gonna be my character
is Gabriel Kinslow constable Gabriel
Kenzo and he's the Mountie of Brookfield
a few months before this season begins
my character was shot
oh and so there's some residual effects
being shot that Kerri he's still dealing
with for sure shot great most definitely
is my character is Chuck Stewart who is
part of that traditional ranch life so
he's the town veterinarian and he's also
like a stocks mint there's this
interesting like what is his calling
where is he gonna end up like is he
gonna take the veterinarian route for
his passion for animals or is he gonna
go and stay with the tradition your
character Chuck he's got an accent yeah
can we hear a little can you say a
little you know my posture changes and
then you know the character kind of
comes out I Slough it's a little bit
it's complicated yeah it's almost like
Bradley Cooper in when stars Jackson
mane vibes
yes can you tease what it is that your
characters gonna go through and why
you're excited for fans to watch it all
unfold
Gabriel Kinslow coming back to town in
the first episode that's that's how we
open it's really interesting to watch
how the different characters in the town
react to it some are nervous about that
some are not too happy about it and some
are thrilled it's nice to have those
relationships and then also kind of
people treat me a little weird and at a
distance so yeah it's good it's good he
kind of kind of stirs the pot a little
bit oh he does yeah just in terms of you
know putting his job and and the pride
of wearing the uniform yeah yeah and it
complicates things do a company's
relationships and we'll see how that
unfolds with Lillian as well thank you
for feeding my horse
should he be on the boardwalk
[Music]
watch in the road we love watching
relationships unfold what kind of
romance is in store for your character
this season
it's very passionate is it yeah yeah
it's the relationships in the show I
think down to a tee they're very
passionate relationships I know that
Greg and Jocelyn have a very interesting
love story and then of course milena
myself are starting to kind of explore
that as well Williams love life is her
first priority it is definitely the
children family all that first but
handsome man walks by and is interested
maybe interesting I don't know he's
constable a romantic guy I think he is
yeah yeah so does he court Louis I think
that he has a lot of respect for her
that's the first scene where they meet
is is one where he finds out about the
orphanage and as soon as that
information is dropped he kind of looks
at her in a different way so are things
heating up with the mounting thank you
very well smashingly great friends I
think and I gotta ask if there's gonna
be any sort of a love triangle this
season because you mentioned
complications yeah who's a character
named Sam who comes in we'll see I mean
we'll see how did Lillian reactant and
where's her mind dad I think Lillian
isn't used to this kind of attention
right off the baton and I think when she
starts to realize then it might be
heading down more of a romantic path
it's maybe a little jarring and
unexpected but then can't help but also
enjoy a little bit I grow say any job
what's it been like working with RJ RJ
is a gem he's so kind he's so lovely
he gets on with everybody he is just
like the most wonderful person to work
with I couldn't have asked for a better
seat partner and potential partner
potential she's been involved in the
project for quite a long time and we got
along really really well she's just a
funny person so it just it created a
very comfortable kind of family like
environment right away being a farm boy
makes you an expert know being a
veterinarian does love arc is pretty
epic her love interest is the son of
someone who hates her her new family so
she she's she wanted but can't be it's
very exciting
we're so drawn to each other so there's
electricity there spot right after that
it's two very you know opinionated
people Grace has got so much gumption
and and but she's also got you know big
barriers up from her history and past
and Chuck's Chuck's just he's drawn to
that right away
and throughout the series you know Chuck
doesn't really take no for an answer and
she's got a lot of knows she makes him
really work for it and so he's pursuing
her heart yeah he's persistent and and I
and eventually like that persistence is
gonna come to a some sort of reward I
always think of her like kind of nervous
and anxious and like yeah especially
with Chuck she's like I like you what do
I do
would you say Chuck is a romantic guy
Chuck is definitely a romantic guy he
likes to be in control of doing good
deeds and that sometimes he crossed the
line a little bit and she puts him in
his business she does she puts him in
his place that she's teaching him a lot
of just things about being a man and
doing it gracefully it's a cool journey
between her and I but the competition is
still there because we're both a little
stubborn and we're both like you know my
way is Right syndrome is there at all a
love triangle or those two real
struggles gonna be getting the family to
agree that they should be together it
started with the family but a love
triangle was kind of introduced into
love interest situation in mooseville
well it's kind of a girl that arrives
from Chuck's past for grace that through
the series it's like you never we have
all sorts of different interesting
good-looking characters that come in and
even when we get the script sometimes
we're like this guy like you know you
got as Chuck with me I was like wait a
minute who is this guy you never know
who's a threat or who's you know who
they're really into there's a lot of
there's just a lot of it's very
ambiguous I think that's gonna be the
greatest arc of chucks character is like
does he get the girl it certainly
brought me likeness Hotel
speaking of charming so I assume most of
your scenes are with Greg yes what is it
like working with him how are you
fostering that chemistry working with
Greg is great I am we are pretty similar
I think out of the whole cast Greg and I
are the most similar take the same
supplements
yeah he came in my he came in the hotel
room and it was like oh my counter looks
exactly we have all like the vitamin E
the moment we got here it was like there
was just this bond we just get each
other
Rupert her dog we bonded great over him
like we you know we take him out for
walks sometimes like I like like to take
him and give her a break why should fans
tune in to when hope calls what is it
that you want people to feel when
they're at home watching you on their
screens I would love for people to just
be able to watch the beautiful
relationships that are forming both in
family and between friends and potential
love partners as well is it's gonna
really give people a chance to
appreciate their own family and the
people that they have in their lives
because you see other people from
different views and different walks of
life you've lost that sense of community
where we all got we've all gotten
individualized and it's like that's what
I'm excited for people to see just to
get that reminder of like community I
think it's a really wonderful world and
a wonderful group of people and know
that the actors are having fun with each
other and really you know really doing
our best to give it to the audience here
because such an incredible fan base then
they deserve it I hope they can just
connect with us and relate to the show I
think everyone
loves the values like the family values
I think that's needed right now you know
just a nice show you don't have
nightmares at night after watching it a
nice warm beautiful show that everyone
is working really hard on and lots of
romance
[Music]